[Music]
it is
9 21 we are here in seattle at the
university village center
and this is the brand new apple store
that is opening up i'm so excited me and
jenna flew in last night
just to be here for the grand opening
and this store is absolutely beautiful
we stopped by last night to take a look
at it before they close down the apple
store that is right next to it which was
open in september of 2003
and this one is brand new they've been
working on it for over three years i
think this actually used to be like a
parking lot or something there's also a
living roof on the top
there's like bees and flowers and grass
so we have about seven minutes before
the store opens let's go take a look at
the line
come on from where
first in line are you first in line
yeah high five yes i love
first in line people how long have you
been waiting i've been here since
6 a.m oh okay that's not too bad that's
good yeah we once slept outside for 56
hours for the iphone 6.
that i don't want to do it again
hi come on
everybody has like apple shirts and hats
and everybody has an iphone and apple
watches this is so great
hi look at this you've got like one of
the old school apple logos
this is so cool thank you
hi hello
[Music]
okay we got a long way to go
i'll wait have you ever been laughed in
line today
today's the day
[Music]
oh my goodness look what you brought
this is so cool and in front of the
apple store too
well thanks for coming by thank you for
coming here so we're a minute away for
the grand opening and here is the line
behind me
i signed me an iphone
[Music]
the employees are getting so close to
the door so that's what we're gonna do
we're gonna film them going in jen and
then we're gonna run to the back and
then we're gonna run in so they'll clap
for us does that sound good
i think so okay good a lot of run oh my
gosh it's happening it's happening it's
happening
first in line
this is so exciting
we're going in
all right
[Applause]
we're inside we're inside
how old are you now i am 24. okay oh wow
so you were you were like
i was 14 when i started watching you and
no one else was watching youtube so this
is insane
my little town in england's here okay
you're in england
i'm from france i'm from france but i
was in new england in boarding school
and now i'm here in a working tank
this is incredible small world high five
high five
so we're gonna get a shot of the roof we
have to go up on the creighton barrel
balcony so we can get a good shot of it
so let's go
also i'm wearing a pineapple shirt
because i couldn't find an apple shirt
so it was the closest thing to an apple
that i could find
you get it oh there it now
[Music]
so we made it up to the roof which gives
us a really great view of the living
room which is kind of amazing
unfortunately we can't go all the way up
there now let's go through and do a tour
of the entire store we're starting on
the other side you saw us go in on the
entrance so this is the back side of it
so let's go in and check it out but
before we do
there's the old store it's all wrapped
in navy blue
they have such an awesome open floor
plan so it basically is bringing the
outside
in they actually have a tree in the
middle of the store
this is jenna's present i'm gonna get
her this and i think i'm gonna get
myself this one
i like the white with the black oh i'm
shopping
the best part about this is when it does
snow in seattle they said that this is
going to kind of turn into like a snow
globe
come on let's go see what else we can
see so this is where we came in at
when the doors opened this is the front
of the store i love that they have this
open patio area so you can kind of just
come sit
drink coffee have fun be with the people
i want to be where the people love
i want to see wanna see them typing
that's good huh so today at apple
let's have a seat at 11 a.m they're
having studio hours for all projects
12 pm basics for ipad this screen is
massive
let's put it in perspective of my body
[Music]
so continuing on from the big tv this is
the back of the store so we basically
have just made one big
loop there's a board room
wow is that fancy laptops
imacs aplenty
i've got gadgets and gizmos
oh look how nice this one is
whoa
oh wow
this is much better than the first
version that they came out with i've got
some things on my wish list
what does he do is he an ar bear
oh my gosh yes
oh my gosh
okay okay this is actually really neat
look at him dancing oh oh okay
we'll see yourself out i need a bigger
tabletop
well i think we've officially seen the
whole story let's walk out here to the
patio
and now we're back where we started what
a beautiful
beautiful store
like it's crazy how awesome it is
well guys that is the new apple store
here at the university village center in
seattle this was so
awesome i hope you guys enjoyed the tour
let me know if you guys ever make it out
here and if there's another apple store
you'd like me to check out
make sure you guys leave those in the
comments below and maybe i'll come and
visit you guys at your apple store
does it really no real are you serious
oh
because there is one in new york that
says don't touch oh no
okay well let's go back in
[Music]
this is the peach i like this
because i feel like this is too similar
so i shouldn't do that should i buy
toothbrush
no
[Laughter]
but here's the thing guess what
all of the new watch bands are all sold
out here already
so we might have to get them online
here's yours jen
thank you again a gift
one of the really cool store design
features is all of the lines
match up evenly everything is perfect
and symmetric so even these little lines
here
on the sidewalk everything matches up
and the inside from the tile floor to
the walls
all of the seams are even and matched
2003-2018 all closed up
so is it really close yeah but it's over
there now
that's the new store so we've been
talking about getting coffee this whole
video well guess what we did
and now they've told us that we have to
try the chairs
it really is a perfect sit
i am living my best apple life right now
okay i guess that's the end of the video
now
bye
[Music]